is cinema dying it depends on who you
ask but there's one thing that almost
everyone agrees on
things are changing i mean things have
been changing in the industry over the
last decade but the rate of change
just accelerated in the past few years
franchise films went from being the
occasional temple features to the
dominant offering in theaters
as big media companies discovered that
projects attached to already established
entities were far more financially
successful than original ideas
a flood of remakes sequels reboots and
franchises flooded into theaters
meanwhile as ticket sales trended down
online streaming became dominant
netflix rose to prominence and while it
begrudgingly gave in
and crossed over into traditional
distribution releasing some of its films
in theaters so it could qualify for
academy awards
every other major studio or media
company frantically
and desperately crossed over into
streaming distribution
racing to release their own streaming
services
a company that used to just make
computers and ipods
now began producing russo brothers
movies and spielberg and jj abrams
television the line
between tv and film has also been
blurring for a while
with some films starting to look more
like tv long stories
with reoccurring characters drawn out
over multiple episodes
and many tv shows starting to look more
like films
broken into smaller pieces the way we
consume media
has changed dramatically there used to
be
the cinema and your television as ways
you could watch something
but now there are theaters tvs tablets
computers and phones
in the midst of all this change the
pandemic hits theaters shut down the big
money makers for many companies were
essentially halted
meanwhile netflix continued business as
usual and exceeded growth expectations
in 2020.
late in the year after the one film
warner brothers dared to release in
theaters failed to bring in numbers
the studio announced that they'd release
films
in theaters and on their streaming
service hbo max simultaneously
throughout 2021 a move that for better
or worse will
likely have historical impact on the
film industry and one that's seriously
upset
filmmakers like denny villeneuve and
ultimately led to christopher nolan
breaking off his long-term relationship
with the studio
in the midst of all of this sits martin
scorsese
a 78 year old director someone who's
been alive for half of cinema's short
history as an art form
he's directed 24 feature films almost as
many documentaries
and in the process he hasn't resisted
technological progress
in his own work embracing digital
cameras cgi
producing television and releasing his
latest film on netflix
what streaming means and how that's
going to
define a new form of cinema i'm not sure
he's not someone you could call a
luddite or
unwilling to change i think it's uh not
just an evolving of cinema but it's a
revolution
and yet from his perspective something
he loves dearly
the thing martin scorsese calls cinema
looks
to be in danger of extinction but i'm
also concerned
i'm almost very concerned
is he right this video is sponsored by
mubi sign up at movie.com
thomasflight for 30 days of free access
to hand hand-curated cinemas
i recently watched fellini's eight and a
half it's a marvelous film with a camera
that
drifts through dream-like scenes and
symbolic imagery
i mean just look at how the perspective
of this shot drifts from
first person to third person without
cutting
perhaps it was this very shot that
inspired scorsese to do a similar
maneuver in the departed decades later
it's a film where the telling of its
story is inseparable from its use of
camera movement
editing and staging the visual language
of film
and i can imagine just how exciting it
would have been to walk into a theater
in 1963 and see this for the first time
on the big screen
not knowing you and everyone packed into
the theater were about to watch what
would become
one of the most influential art house
films in history
and the conversations that must have
happened afterwards about
what it possibly could have meant that
excitement is what martin scorsese
describes in his new essay for harper's
magazine
an essay that continues to expand on his
concern that the cinema he's known and
loved
is facing threat of extinction he's been
talking about this for
a while stirring up controversy by
saying that
superhero films it's not cinema it's
something else something closer to
theme park rides but in his new essay he
expounds
further talking about how the dynamics
of streaming services
are changing the way we consume and
think about film
but to know if scorsese is right about
cinema dying we have to first
understand what cinema is at least the
way he's defining it
marty what are you doing
what did he say first there's gonna be a
lot of
layers here so hang on i'm going to try
to break it down as clearly as i can
because underneath all of this is not
just one man's opinion about going to
the movies
but a much broader discussion about an
art form
its impact on our culture how it's
changing
and its future
and recently the joker was inspired by
your cinema i know by your movies but
do you also consider it as a theme park
movie i don't know about that i know the
film very well
and i know todd very well my producer
emma
tellinger costco produced it yeah yeah
so um
it's an interesting question a little
over a year ago i made a video
attempting to illustrate visually what i
think scorsese means by
cinema he's not saying cinema is better
than superhero films
just that cinema is a specific art form
and that while marvel type films may
represent a new art form that takes
talent and skill to make and that
there's nothing wrong with enjoying
it's still something distinct from
cinema it's a distinction that when you
make it no matter how clearly you say it
isn't a judgment of quality
fans of both marvel and other big
franchise films tend to take offense at
but it's also a distinction that's
tricky to
articulate from the first shot you know
you know when there's an author there
and you know when it's personal and you
know it
you can feel it you can feel it come
through every moment every shot
every and the actors and every piece of
it and it
and it just doesn't miss you and i don't
know that i can explain it better than
that
but you just know it when you see it in
many ways it's more easily shown than
said which is what i was trying to do
with that video
but it's not just a separation between
drama and action films i think the way
scorsese is defining it
has to do with intent and use of film
form in a specific way
helpful in understanding exactly what
scorsese is concerned with
and why he doesn't see superhero films
as cinema
is joker
a film that in many ways stands on the
shoulders of and channels scorsese's own
work
a movie that scorsese was even in talks
to direct but that he ultimately passed
on
i know the script very well so that it
has it's really energy and
incredible joakim and all that sort of
thing so you have a remarkable work but
uh for me ultimately i don't know if i
if i
make the uh uh i should say the next
step which is to
this character developing into a comic
book character he makes concessions that
joker stands apart from most superhero
films but for him
some kind of line is still crossed by
associating the film
with a comic book character develops
into an abstraction
that doesn't mean it's bad art it could
be but it's not for me
that changes the film in some way for
him understanding why is crucial to
understanding his concerns
as a whole if we look at the top 50
grossing films in the box office over
the last
decade there are only three movies that
aren't a remake
reboot or part of some larger franchise
or series
these three movies are zootopia the
secret life of pets
and bohemian rhapsody the other 47
movies on this list aren't
contained self-sufficient individual
stories but part of
million or billion dollar entertainment
enterprises
including extensive merchandising
related products
and even theme parks let me introduce
you to
avengers campus coming to disney
california adventure park
this rendering shows some of the
experiences attractions
and surprises we're super hyped for
because i saw this happening
in the early 70s in hollywood where
heads of studios were talking about
really
wanting to have in the industry uh a
disney world for scorsese i think the
connection a film has to
this larger commercial enterprise
changes it at its core
tour the studio it's like a theme park
ride well why not put a film in there
i want to make the film part of that
experience and i agree
you can't really untangle these movies
from their place in a massive corporate
enterprise we had a really
hard time getting that film made which
seems insane today
now seeing how well the movie's done we
spent a year at warner brothers and i
saw emails back and forth literally
where they said
does he realize meaning me does he
realize we sell joker pajamas
at target and so is that true it's very
what you're saying doesn't the movies
come first the pajamas come
second like are the pajamas dictating
the movies no
we might be tilting this the the the
scales
away from that creative viewing
experience and away
from away from movies as an art form i
can't stress this enough before you come
in with your angry comments about how i
hate marvel i'm no fun i'm pretentious
or whatever
scorsese and i are not saying that these
things should not be made
the sense of theme park has always been
there it's always been it's not bad
we used to love to go to amusement parks
you know but now in an amusement park
you have the film by all means
disney and warner brothers should keep
cranking out big budget superhero films
and you may continue to go watch them
and enjoy them and i'm not looking down
on anyone for it what i
am saying and what i think scorsese
cares about
is that in the midst of all of this
there's a place for artistic narratives
that
aren't tied to larger corporate
financial enterprise
that there's a value in telling stories
that stand
in his harper's essay instead of trying
to define cinema by
talking about what it isn't scorsese
instead tries to define the form by
holding up
a defining example he says you can say a
lot of things about fellini's movies but
here's one thing that
is incontestable they are cinema
fellini's work goes a long way towards
defining the art form
so when scorsese says cinema he's
talking about a certain kind of movie
and an approach to movie making but
there's another complicating factor in
his definition
scorsese also is talking about the
specific experience of seeing
a film in a theater for scorsese the way
a film
is consumed and is meant to be consumed
is part of what defines it as cinema
if i can try to summarize what i think
scorsese's definition of cinema is
it's a type of experience of leaving
your house to go to a place where you
watch a film with other people
and the film you watch is not just part
of a commercial enterprise produced by a
massive corporation and based around
existing characters and material but a
unique
individual story that is crafted and
presented with special care to film
language tradition
and form i completely agree with him
that that experience is a unique and
distinct thing
while i'm not elitist about it and
wouldn't say that the theater is the
only valid viewing experience for movies
or that you're not really watching a
film if you watch it at home or watch it
on your
phone i think there is definitely
something distinct about watching a film
in a theater it has a communal aspect
you can't pause the film the sound
quality and image quality are hopefully
better
louder and bigger and i'm completely
open to the argument that those
differences aren't really that big of a
deal but i personally think
these differences in presentation do
affect how you perceive
a film and its story but here's the
thing that thing scorsese is talking
about even if it is distinct
is cinema really the right word for it
here i'm not really sure
on one hand i think using the term and
labeling marvel films not cinema
probably makes scorsese's point a little
more controversial than it needs to be
making it sound like he's making a
quality judgment rather than a
descriptive one
but on the other hand what else would
you call it
what better word is there to make this
distinction
i'm not sure but no matter what you
label it the experience i described
above the one scorsese label cinema
that specific thing does seem to be
dying or at least
significantly diminishing in cultural
influence
but this is where i'm conflicted cinema
especially as it
involves the communal theatrical
experience might be at the beginning of
a slow death but if you're interested in
the art of moving images
and the rich unique stories being told
with them
apart from that communal theatrical
experience it's maybe the best time to
be alive
for anyone who is interested in the art
form of cinema and film history there's
now
for most people actually the possibility
of access to an
unparalleled selection of films and film
history
and the era scorsese came up in when he
was watching eight and a half it was
before home video was even widely
available at that time you were
reliant on theaters in your city or town
to find and curate
films for you and unless you had the
extravagant resources to collect
35 millimeter film prints or access to a
library
of prints much of film history would
have been completely inaccessible to you
these days with a subscription to a few
streaming services
you can have access to more great cinema
than you would
ever have time to conceivably watch and
in a way it's the same technology that
is killing cinema that's
making this possible you may not be able
to have as many
experiences in theaters in the same way
scorsese did and that's
certainly sad but the trade-off so far
has meant
unparalleled access to a world of cinema
for those who are interested but there
are also
downsides to this new availability
the cultural influence of moving image
entertainment as a whole whether it's
movies tv
youtube videos or tick tocks is at an
all-time high and in a way the real
struggle for scorsese cinema
is not even to differentiate itself from
marvel type films
it's to even be able to differentiate
itself from
any kind of moving image entertainment
in this vast world
of content we are surrounded by a
torrent of moving images
it is inescapably part of our cultural
language fellini's eight and a half
a four-hour movie that wasn't shown in
theaters a tv show that's 90 minutes in
length
a web series that's now a tv show a new
indie film
a blockbuster release and for that
matter a video of your friend on
vacation
or me talking to you right now all get
lumped together into a giant bin
we call content film critic matt zoller
seitz says
in an article addressing this issue
content refers to a piece of
entertainment that can be delivered any
number of ways and that's defined
less by its story characters source
material or presentational medium
cinema or tv than by its brand identity
marvel its corporate parentage disney
and its ability to get hundreds
of millions of people talking about it
all at once to distill
all moving images down to content i
think is to value them only for what
they provide
to the companies that serve them to us
something to be traded for subscription
dollars
or a way to grab your attention to trade
it for advertising dollars
yeah movie goers are better defined
today as movie watchers
you know a lot of that movie watching
now mostly happens at home that's just
the way it is okay
i think treating everything as content
divorces the viewer from the person
creating the content and what they have
to say
hence i feel it's kind of becoming more
and more
uh tailored towards a consumer
experience
because movies are they're slotted into
consumer categories before they're even
given a chance to breathe
it turns the viewer from someone
participating in an artistic expression
to just a passive consumer of
entertainment or
a product if i really wanted to lose
viewers at this point i put up a big
title that says the importance of visual
literacy
but i'm not going to do that because i
want people to keep watching and i know
that as
boring and nerdy as some of this stuff
sounds
if you're a fan of movies want to be a
filmmaker a storyteller
a critic or you're just somebody who
watches a lot of stuff
this is important in this giant bin of
content it's easy for the distinguishing
artistic approaches to each work
or even medium to get lost you might not
see these distinctions
as important but the traditions of how
images are manipulated
what we call film form are the
foundation of an incredibly important
and influential visual grammar that
impacts us every day as a part of
everything
we watch and yet we barely acknowledge
its
existence we teach literacy grammar and
spelling in school but
while the average person spends more
time watching moving images than reading
or writing
the idea of visual literacy as something
that's
worth even recognizing the existence of
much less
teaching is often scoffed at and
ridiculed as pretentious
and if you think i'm being pretentious
exclusionary elitist or even just
boring just keep in mind i'm not saying
anything that limits you from
enjoying entertainment all i'm doing is
inviting you to gain a better
understanding of the visual language
that makes up the entertainment you
watch which i believe will make your
life richer
and better and even increase your
appreciation
of that entertainment giving you a
better understanding of the stories
you're consuming but to be able to study
teach and learn that language i think we
need to preserve the experience of
cinema but you know we can't have a
future of our art form
without knowing its past even among
fans of film few use the opportunity to
really dig into this rich medium
and its history because the great stuff
just sits in one giant bin
indistinguishable from everything else
we call content
anybody can upload their music to itunes
or
maybe even spotify these these days it
doesn't really matter because if people
don't know how to find you
it doesn't matter why the great cinema
the great tv
even the great youtube videos the ones
that won't just kill a couple hours for
you but will
shape the way you see the world
challenge your preconceptions
and show you new experiences get lost in
the flood of
content that gets suggested to you
simply because
an algorithm knows it will grab and hold
your attention
or because it's what's most suitable for
advertising
like those 47 out of the 50 top grossing
films from the last decade
much of what is dominant on streaming
platforms
is defined by its commercial economic
viability
and that's not a great environment to
promote and foster
the creation of good art the reason
remakes
reboots and sequels are more
commercially viable
is because they're a safe bet financiers
know that these things have a built-in
audience who will pay to see them
what is safe financially is what's
worked in the past
and what has been done before but good
art is something that takes risks
challenges norms and develops the medium
it's rarely a safe bet
and if we create a landscape that only
promotes and encourages
content that is a safe bet will cut
ourselves off from
access to new interesting art that is
innovative
and original where things go from here
with theaters with the industry
i don't know streaming services could
lead to increasingly mediocre and safe
content or they could potentially fund a
revival of unique art
sparking new waves and movements and
there's been evidence to indicate both
of these things
and maybe they'll both happen
simultaneously cinema might
fade out of the theaters with massive
franchises
being the only thing that can still
survive there or maybe it'll be
relegated to
art house movie theaters but the cinema
of unique
artistic individual stories is still out
there and accessible
if you know where to look i know the
business has changed
and everything changes all the time
impermanence that's what it's about
it's wide open though now you can watch
everything
anytime anywhere and it puts a burden on
you
on the viewer if it is preserved it will
be because people like you
are willing to see its value and seek it
out what is the value of cinema
cinema while it can be entertaining
won't just entertain you for two hours
it will offer you new perspectives show
you the world
give you a glimpse of the future or the
past
force you to examine yourself to
contemplate life
and reshape the way you see all the
other moving images
that surround you every individual
filmmaker amounts to
more than the number of awards they've
won or the amount of monies the pictures
make
and every individual viewer that's you
amounts to
more much more than the data
that has been collected about them huh
one of the solutions that scorsese
proposes to the issues with streaming
services
is a heavier focus on curation and he
specifically name drops some streaming
services that
do curation well one of them is mubi
my sponsor for this video
movie's curation really is its selling
point i've discovered
so much great cinema through mubi that i
truly wouldn't have found if it hadn't
been for my movie subscription they hand
pick a new film
every day and they offer an explanation
for why
it's worth your time it was an
experimental short film that i randomly
stumbled across
on mubi that inspired me to make an
experimental short film last year
while scorsese holds fellini up as a
defining example of cinema
someone else i'd personally choose as a
defining example is andre tarkovsky
and right now on mubi in the u.s you can
watch the sacrifice
and his film nostalgia when you sign up
at movie.com thomasflight you'll get an
extended
30-day free trial i recommend you just
go check it out
and start watching something that looks
interesting to you and it will be an
interesting experience because
another human hand chose that film
because they thought it was
worth watching sign up at mubi.com
thomasflight to support my channel movie
and cinema all at once
[Music]
you